Uh, Mr. Cosby,
we're your lawyers.
I think you know
why we've called this meeting.
Of course, I do.
Because I did the ludes, and
the so-called raping, then
the licking and the bah, bah.
And the spewing and the fluids,
you know, all over the place.
Well, well, well,
talking like that,
uh, in a deposition
is not a good idea.
Yeah, we're gonna need
a really good defense,
a story you can stick to.
My story is that I had a hit
TV show, and I danced,
and I went, bah, bah,
bah, boom, boo, boo.
Boo. That's how we opened
the show. It was amazing.
-That's my show.
-MAN: Um, how about this?
Michael Jackson,
Mike Tyson and you.
-Mm-hmm. -What do all three
of you have in common?
COSBY:
Mah!
Come on now! We did the alleged
raping with the ludes.
I did my knock 'em down,
I did the putting...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You're all successful black men.
-COSBY: Yes.
-Okay?
Systematically taken down
because white America
couldn't stomach it.
-Just like O.J.
-COSBY: Yes.
Like O.J., the Simpson,
not the juice. Bah.
Mr. Cosby, it's a conspiracy,
a race-based conspiracy.
COSBY:
Correct.
Cappuccino?
I mean, I may regret this,
but that doesn't look delicious,
right?
I could use a little afternoon
pick-me-up. I mean...
-Yeah. Milk. -Oh, look at that.
Come on.
He's putting sugar or whatever
that is in it. It's fine.
There you go, young man.
Have a sip. Bah!
-Go! Go! -Uh, maybe these women
were paid to bring you down.
Hmm? Maybe they entrapped you.
Yes. You were just trying
to mentor them.
-You're the real victim.
-Good.
-COSBY: That's exactly right.
-MAN: Yes!
And then, I did the alleged
sucking on the toes,
and the woos-woos and, uh, and
the licking of the pudding pop.
-Bah, bah, bah.
-(whooshing)
Smoothie? Hmm?
-I probably shouldn't.
-Bah!
But I did skip lunch, so maybe
just have a little... Mmm!
Delicious?
Is that a banana?
Well, there's some banana
and some ludes.
You know, the secret is
in the ludes.
And that is a great example
of things
we should definitely not say
during a deposition.
Agreed, Counsel. Uh, we need
to be more specific here.
Let's think of some white groups
that would hate you the most.
THEDE:
Yes.
Hate, yes.
White liberals.
Correctamundo.
That is exactly true.
White liberals hate
when you tell black teens
to pull their pants up.
-Yes.
-COSBY: Ugh.
This is precisely
what I've been trying
to tell you all this time.
And these belt-aphobes
are trying to take you down
because you tell teens
to pull their pants up.
That's right.
This can work. I like this.
-Yeah.
-(whirring)
Snow cone?
Oh, that's a fun surprise.
Yes!
Don't mind if I do.
-Really can't see
why I wouldn't. -COSBY: Oh.
To the Cosby
and the getting off,
and not in the sexual way,
but in the legal way. Bah!
Oh!
Cosby, you did it again.
Bah! Bur.
Ooh.